Hi I'm John Green
and this is a video of a cat
wearing a shark costume, riding a roomba
which has 12 million views on youtube
and deservedly so
it is probably the second best video
in the entire world of a cat wearing a shark costume
riding a roomba
beaten out only by this video
of a cat wearing a shark costume
riding a roomba, chasing a duck
here at crash course our videos are watched more than 700,000 times a day
and they are used in thousands of schools around the world
But our most popular single video has 6.8 million views
and that's great
but it's no cat wearing a shark costume riding a roomba
An Internet funded by advertising
is really good at funding
the creation of cat-shark-roomba videos
and that's important because I don't
want to live in a world without such videos.
The ad-funded Internet excels at making
stuff that you will look at or click on
because advertisers care most about how many eyeballs
Are going to see their advertisement. But that Internet
Doesn't necessarily do a good job of
supporting stuff people will love
or that will have a lasting impact on them.
Back in 2012 we were able to start
Crash Course thanks to a grant from Google
but the channel has been able to continue
and grow because of your contributions
on Patreon and because of support from PBS,
the Public Broadcasting Service here
in the United States.
PBS Digital Studios funds a
lot of my favorite educational channels
from Its OK to be Smart,
Physics Girl as well as two
Crash Courses per year
and PBS's Learning Media platform
connects those videos directly
to teachers and students which
broadens our reach, and also gives
schools free resources so they don't have to
pay to license content.
Without PBS there would be only two
Crash Course videos a week around here,
their funding allowed us to create
series in computer science, physics,
astronomy, and US government.
And every day we hear from learners
of all ages how those videos
have helped them understand material
and more importantly, get excited about learning.
Because education is not merely a series of
tortures that one must endure to receive a degree
it's the process of becoming more aware of
and engaged with the universe and
your place in it and
we really hope that Crash Course can play a small role
in that process.
So you've probably heard in the new recently
that there have been proposals to drastically
cut or even eliminate federal funding
for the Corporation for Public Broadcasting
which provides critical support to local
television and radio stations.
Public Broadcasting's federal funding
amounts to about $1.35 per American per year
now obviously I'm biased
but I think they create a lot of value
with that money and not just through
Crash Course and the art assignment.
So listen, most American high school students
know what Crash Course is
but I think it's safe to say that many
US senators and congresspeople don't.
And if you care about Crash Course or other
or other PBS Digital shows I want to
ask you to take a few minutes and contact
your member of Congress and let them know.
Now when asked to do this I used to be like
"Yeah whatever I don't like calling strangers for pizza...
...let alone to voice a political opinion."
But now that I've made a few calls
on issues that are important to me
I've realized that (1), it's easy,
and (2), it really helps your elected leaders to
understand what's important to you.
They want to hear from their constituents
and they benefit from it
so I put some resources in the video info
below, thanks to everybody who contacts
their representatives and senators
to let them know that there is value
in PBS and in the local stations
and content they support.
Also, you can let your friends know
that you support PBS by talking
your favorite PBS content and
and using the #ILOVEPBS
and you can learn much more about
the value PBS provides over at
PBS.org/value.
I'm sorry to interrupt your regularly
scheduled Crash Course but the
but the future of PBS is very important
to the future of Crash Course so thank you for
watching, thanks again for contacting
your representatives and senators
and as we say in my hometown,
don't forget to be awesome.